el 8 de agosto del año 2008 el mismo día
que arrancaban los Juegos Olímpicos de
Beijing de ese mismo año el ejército
ruso lanzaba su invasión a gran escala
sobre Georgia
el evento más importante de la década
para china esos Juegos Olímpicos que
iban a culminar el proceso de plena
incorporación del país comunista la
comunidad internacional iba a ser
empañado por Vladimir Putin y sus
aspiraciones belicistas por aquel
entonces todavía no estaba sin pin a los
mandos de China sino que era su
predecesor cuyntao quien reaccionó
discretamente pero profundamente
irritado con Moscú el mismo día que la
llama olímpica iluminaría china por
primera vez
queridos amigos amigas Aunque ha llovido
mucho desde entonces hay costumbres que
nunca cambian como si de una especie de
déjà Vu se tratara Putin tomó la
decisión de invadir Ucrania justo en las
fechas en las que china organizaba otros
Juegos Olímpicos en este caso los de
invierno de Pekín 2022 de hecho se cree
Queen le pidió al líder ruso que dejara
su invasión para después de la clausura
y sea esto no cierto la cuestión es que
solo cuatro días después de terminados
estos juegos las hordas de Putin se
lanzaron sobre Ucrania desde entonces la
actitud de la República popular china ha
sido tremendamente ambigua y errática
pero si hay algo que ha quedado muy
claro Y es que jinping cada vez está más
lejos de sus predecesores
durante todo este tiempo durante un
largo año de guerra y a pesar de Los
Terribles crímenes cometidos por el
ejército ruso El dictador chino ha
permanecido callado al menos hasta ahora
porque Seguro seguro que esta imagen va
a tardar en olvidarse
[Música]
sí finalmente se produjo la imagen que
algunos dudaban que se fuera a producir
y que otros anunciaban como Inevitable
los dictadores de China y de Rusia hacen
Pain y Vladimir Putin juntos en una
Cumbre bilateral en el mismísimo Moscú
un año después del inicio de la guerra
no ha sido la primera vez que se
encuentran desde el inicio de la
invasión pero si ha sido la primera vez
que lo hacen al más alto nivel y en el
marco de una Cumbre bilateral Quizás por
eso Muchos han interpretado que esta
visita decía Moscú es todo un
espaldarazo Putin una manera de
legitimar al mandatario ruso en la
escena internacional y quizás también de
blanquear sus operaciones más aún cuando
la visita se produjo tan solo unos pocos
días después de que saltaran noticias
como esta los jueces de La cpi emiten
una orden de arresto para Vladimir Putin
por presuntos crímenes de Guerra sin
embargo esto es tan solo la nota pie de
página Lo cierto es que la visita de
sillín Pinar a Rusia consiste en algo
más que simples apretones de manos o
sonrisas forzadas fue ante todo el
último intento de Pekín de convertirse
de una vez por todas en antagónica
Washington la alternativa clara al
liderazgo occidental ahora bien
significa todo esto que china finalmente
Se pondrá del lado de Rusia en la guerra
es Pekín realmente neutral como ellos
defienden ser qué demonios pretenden
realmente los chinos con esta aparenta
aproximación a Putin Quién tiene la
sartén por el mango en toda esta
historia queridos amigos amigas En este
vídeo vamos a responder a estas y otras
preguntas atentos
[Música]
el orden multipolar
fijaos en esta llamativa imagen en ella
podéis ver a wangi director de la
comisión central de asuntos exteriores
del partido comunista chino el principal
asesor de política exterior de junto a
los representantes de Arabia saudí e
Irán dos países que en teoría se odian
pero que ahora han decidido restablecer
sus relaciones diplomáticas y que lo han
hecho gracias a la mediación de China y
aunque no es muy común ver a los chinos
como mediadores en problemas
internacionales parece que ahora es
precisamente el nuevo camino que quiere
seguir el régimen chino y de esta forma
el conflicto entre Rusia y Ucrania
Parece ser su siguiente objetivo
a finales del pasado mes de febrero de
2023 coincidiendo con el primer
aniversario de la guerra china presentó
un plan de 12 puntos para al menos en
teoría dar una solución política al
conflicto en realidad este es una
especie de plan lentejas o lo tomas o lo
dejas ni siquiera consultaron la opinión
de Ucrania sobre los 12 puntos
presentados y tampoco es que sea muy
concisos de hecho la mayoría de los
puntos incluyen cosas extremadamente
generales como respetar la soberanía de
todos los países besar las hostilidades
o reducir los riesgos estratégicos Pero
lo importante es que con este documento
china ya tenía su plan de paz
en teoría ahora los chinos van a empezar
a trabajar para ver cómo se pueden hacer
realidad esos puntos Y eso es
seguramente lo que explica noticias como
estás en los medios los viajes de los
líderes europeos a China destacan el
papel de Pekín como promotor de la Paz
como saben la semana que viene viajaré a
la capital de Beijing en viaje oficial y
en ese sentido Quiero agradecer
lógicamente al presidente chinos su
invitación porque creo que es importante
que desde Europa afiancemos una
cooperación entre Europa y China ante
retos globales que trascienden las
fronteras pero claro la duda el gran
interrogante toda esta historia Es
realmente podemos considerar a China
como un actor neutral entre Rusia y
Ucrania es capaz de actuar como un país
mediador en este conflicto
[Música]
Y es que bueno que queréis que os diga
palabras como estas no ayudan
y no sé a vosotros pero que sí le diga
Putin que están impulsando un cambio
juntos no parece la mejor carta de
presentación para convertirse en el
mediador en este conflicto sin embargo
un momento porque quedarse con estas
imágenes y ya está sería un análisis
terriblemente simple y terriblemente
desafortunado de toda esta situación
Pekín habla de su plan de paz Pero y si
a China realmente no le interesa que la
guerra termine pronto Sí sí me habéis
escuchado bien esa es exactamente la
pregunta que tenemos que responder
Y es que veréis me explico inicialmente
esta guerra ha sido una [__] para
China de repente todo el mundo empezó a
preocuparse por la seguridad nacional el
apoyo occidental ucraniano superó
barreras que pueden ser consideradas
como un precedente por ejemplo para
Taiwán Estados Unidos mejoró mucho su
posición internacional y se permitió el
lujo de restringir la venta de
tecnología avanzada a la propia China y
para colmo pues la ralentización
económica mundial contribuyó a que el
crecimiento económico del gigante 2022
se quedará prácticamente en la mitad del
objetivo del gobierno sin embargo de
perdidos al río eso parece ser lo que ha
pensado silvin y ahora podemos encontrar
tres grandes motivos que explican como
los chinos quieren sacar tajada de la
guerra y el primero de ellos tiene que
ver con la pasta con los beneficios
económicos extraordinarios que china
está teniendo por las sanciones
occidentales a Rusia creéis un ejemplo
concreto de todo esto Pues fijaos en
este gráfico
por supuesto y tal y como os podéis
imaginar detrás de las importaciones
chinas está sobre todo la energía
[Música]
la guerra las sanciones y la desconexión
Europea de Rusia le han permitido a
China comprar cantidades récord de gas y
petróleo con fortísimos descuentos justo
además cuando su economía no atraviesa
su mejor momento Rusia necesita Vender
todo lo que puede Aunque ello suponga
vender mucho más barato y los chinos
serían aprovechado de esta forma en los
meses de enero y febrero de 2023 con un
incremento de casi el 24% interanual
Rusia desbancó a Arabia Saudita como el
mayor proveedor petrolero de la
República popular china
por supuesto Rusia no puede inundar
China de petróleo y gas básicamente
porque a carece de la infraestructura
necesaria y ve al contrario que por
ejemplo los alemanes los chinos Siempre
han sido muy pero que muy receloso de su
seguridad energética a comienzos de 2023
la cuota de Rusia en las compras chinas
de energía ya estuvo por encima del 20%.
Así que el margen parece pequeño aún así
Ahora la idea Parece ser sustituir las
compras a través de barcos por tuberías
hablamos por ejemplo de intentar
acelerar los plazos para la construcción
del Power of Siberia 2 un nuevo
gasoducto que podría transportar a
través de más de 2.600 kilómetros hasta
50.000 millones de metros cúbicos de gas
lo que supondría pues duplicar la actual
capacidad de exportación de gas ruso a
China
[Música]
Claro que hay un problema las
estimaciones chinas pasan por importar
unos 38.000 millones de metros cúbicos
de gas para el 2025 mientras que los
rusos bueno digamos que aspiran a poder
venderles casi 100.000 millones de
metros cúbicos para el 2030 y con el
petróleo ocurre tres cuartas partes de
lo mismo digamos que existe una profunda
brecha entre lo que china quiere llegar
a comprar y lo que Rusia quiere vender
Así que para que los chinos acepten
aumentar aún más su exposición
energética Rusia el crimen tendrá que
comprometer precios mucho más bajos dar
garantías y pasar por el Aro de lo que
diga el Tito Sí porque no olvidéis una
cosa esta no es una relación entre
iguales la relación especial entre Rusia
y China puede terminar haciendo que el
primero se convierta en una especie de
estado vasallo del segundo y no no
estamos exagerando Esta es de hecho la
segunda gran ventaja que la guerra puede
tener para china una influencia política
mucho más grande un nuevo grado de
influencia que ellos mismos han
bautizado con nombre y apellido el orden
multipolar
la idea del orden multipolar es juntar a
las esferas de poder de Rusia y de China
es decir al mundo rusófilo y xenófilo
para crear un nuevo eje de poder global
que sirva de contrapeso al poder
estadounidense en todos los campos El
pequeño detalle es que ahora con el
enorme debilitamiento que está sufriendo
Rusia china puede aprovecharse para
imponer sus intereses geopolíticos
económicos y militares sobre cualquier
exigencia rusa
algún ejemplo de por Dónde podrían ir
los tiros pues uno de los posibles
escenarios en los que china podría
utilizar a Rusia para consolidar su
poder sería precisamente África en una
reciente entrega deus hemos hablado
largo y tendido del particular momento
que está atravesando este continente Por
cierto si aún no conocéis os dejo el
enlace en la descripción pero no solo se
trata del campo geoestratégico cuando
hablamos de influencia china también
está el campo económico fijaos Putin le
dijo Así que Rusia está preparada para
cambiar a yuanes en el comercio exterior
básicamente lo que implicaría este
cambio Es que Rusia dejaría de comerciar
en dólares con los países de Asia
latinoamérica y África pasándose al re
Mimi que es del nombre de la moneda de
China que comúnmente se conoce como Joan
de hecho en 2022 la participación del
Joan en los pagos de las exportaciones
rusas aumentó del 0.5 al 16% y por
ejemplo en febrero del 2023 el Joan
superó por primera vez en la historia al
Dólar como la moneda más negociada en la
bolsa de Moscú protagonizó casi el 40%
de todas las transacciones es lo que
muchos ya han denominado como el Petro
Joan Claro que sean exagerado mucho sus
consecuencias el Joan hoy por hoy no
está capacitado para sustituir al Dólar
Por qué Pues básicamente porque carece
de seguridad jurídica y porque china
mantiene grandes controles de capitales
pero aún así Este cambio sí que podría
impulsar la influencia de china en Rusia
y en general en toda la región de Asia
central y amigos amigas por último
tenemos la cuestión militar
[Música]
Rusia está sufriendo un enorme desgaste
militar lo que junto con las sanciones
están teniendo dos consecuencias muy
claras por un lado la capacidad militar
de Rusia se ha visto mermada dejando
prácticamente a China como la única gran
potencia militar en Asia central Por
otra parte cuando la guerra termine y
Rusia necesite adquirir nuevos equipos
militares para sustituir sus pérdidas si
las sanciones no se levantan es probable
que acudan a la industria militar China
para conseguir Hardware y componentes y
no solo Rusia buena parte de los
clientes de este país podrían poco a
poco desplazarse a la industria china
Pues bien esta serían las tres vías con
las que china podría aspirar a sacar
beneficio de todo este embrollo tres
ejes con los que siguen parece querer
compensar la gran [__] que les ha
supuesto la guerra y sabéis que es justo
aquí Cuando llegamos al Gran dilema
atentos
[Música]
el gran dilema
[Aplausos]
[Música]
después de lo que os hemos contado en
este vídeo si tuvierais que responder a
la pregunta que os hacíamos al principio
sobre si china es o no realmente neutral
con Rusia que respuesta daríais pues
seguramente sea que no que china no
tiene una posición neutral básicamente
porque sin Pink ha encontrado un filón
en la guerra para impulsar su particular
agenda de confrontación con occidente
además no olvidéis que la economía china
está empezando a sufrir un montón de
problemas así que nada mejor que tener a
mano un chivo expiatorio y ya sabéis no
la culpa de los problemas no es nuestra
es de la Guerra sin embargo Esta no es
toda la historia justo aquí Hemos
llegado a lo que podemos denominar como
el gran dilemal que se enfrenta al
gobierno chino y es que veréis por un
lado tal y como hemos visto la guerra
puede tener beneficios para la nueva
agenda de sillín pero por otra parte
también implica muchos problemas que los
medios de comunicación habitualmente
pasan por alto
por ejemplo la guerra está haciendo que
el resto de países desea Pacífico estén
ampliando su gasto militar Y acercándose
aún más a Estados Unidos y esto es algo
que puede debilitar estructuralmente las
ambiciones chinas de de La potencia
hegemónica de esta región del mundo al
mismo tiempo también está contribuyendo
a deteriorar aún más las Ya de por si
tensas relaciones económicas comerciales
y políticas de china con occidente que
es justo lo que este país No necesita en
este momento digamos que la guerra ha
hecho que muchos gobiernos Pues perciban
que dictaduras como las de Putin no las
de silvin no son de fiar
Legends insta a llevar a cabo una
política más dura con China antes de su
visita a Pekín China ha pasado Ya la
página de La era de reforma y apertura y
se adentra en una nueva era de seguridad
y control
nuestra relación estar es equilibrada y
se ve cada vez más afectada por las
distorsiones creadas por el sistema de
capitalismo Estatal chino así que
tenemos que reequilibrar esta relación
por eso Hemos presentado la ley de
materias primas críticas para contribuir
a diversificar y asegurar nuestro
abastecimiento
nos centraremos en los acuerdos libre
comercio donde aún no los tenemos como
Nueva Zelanda Australia India y nuestros
socios de la asian y mercos
[Música]
para colmo de más la guerra también está
ralentizando el crecimiento económico
mundial un crecimiento que china
necesita más que nunca para superar
todos los problemas a los que se
enfrenta hablamos de cosas como el
pinchazo de la burbuja inmobiliaria la
crisis tecnológica los problemas
bancarios el emprendimiento de los
gobiernos locales etcétera etcétera y
claro de no lograr superar todos estos
desequilibrios Y si Nuevo Mundo
multipolar con el que tanto sueñan
Podría tener un recorrido muy corto
[Música]
amigos y jijing ha girado intensamente
el timón respecto a sus predecesores y
los resultados pues no han sido
particularmente buenos ahora esta Parece
ser su última apuesta intenta sacar
tajada de la guerra que Rusia ha
provocado en Ucrania Aunque lo cierto Es
que no está claro que china pueda
realmente lograr algún beneficio de toda
esta jugada en cualquier caso lo que sí
sabemos es que ni es un país natural ni
tampoco un régimen particularmente
confiable pero dicho esto Ahora la
pregunta es para ti tienes que china
lograra beneficiarse del actual contexto
geopolítico terminará Rusia
convirtiéndose en una especie de estado
vasallo de Pekín Qué futuro laburáis a
la alianza entre China y Rusia realmente
serán capaces de promover un nuevo orden
mundial queridos amigos amigas dejadnos
por aquí abajo vuestras impresiones y
hablamos debate Y por supuesto si este
vídeo os ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de like y
suscribiros tanto visualpolitik como en
Ómnibus para estar al tanto de todas
nuestras novedades una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]